[موسيقى]
هذه اذن ساعه الطنطوره الطنطوره عباره عن
ساعه شمسيه بنيت من الطوب الطيني بشكل
هرمي اعتمد عليها اهالي المنطقه قديما
لمعرفه الوقت وايضا الاحتفال بدخول
المربعانيه فصل الشتاء موسم الزراعه
[موسيقى]
ربط التاريخ القديم لساعه طنطوره من مئات
السنين الى احياء الحفل السنوي في كل من
الثاني والعشرين من ديسمبر والذي يعني
دخول المربعانيه ويعتبر الوقت الامثل
للزراعه حيث تم ربط المسمى الاشهر للساعه
القديمه طمطوره بالفعاليات واقامه ايضا
مهرجان طنطوره اهم المواسم الشتويه من
خلالها وذلك باطلاق عدد من الفعاليات تحت
مسمى شتاء طنطوره بمحافظه العلا
[موسيقى]
يعود الى الشتاء طنطوره اول مهرجان موسيقي
ثقافي في المملكه العربيه السعوديه ليسعد
زوار العلا بفعاليات فنيه وثقافيه متنوعه
[موسيقى]
باقه من اروع الفعاليات الترفيهيه الفنيه
والثقافيه الحفلات الموسيقيه لالمع نجوم
الفن تقام في قاعه مرايا التحفه الفنيه
[موسيقى]
تنهض قاعه مرايا من الرمال مثل السراب
المرايا العاكسه التي تجعلها اكبر مبنى
عاكس في العالم وفقا لموسوعه جنس للارقام
القياسيه